une expérience vous avec un interview
non moi c'était à l'époque où je
travaillais chez basse rail est toujours
au même endroit où je travaille
aujourd'hui chez h2o oui j'étais en bas
du bureau et j'attendais quelqu'un pour
venir réparer l'imprimante du bureau
comme un gros poste à l'époque
j'attendais en bas et là y'a un mec qui
arrive en jogging plutôt brand et tout
ça tu t'approches de moins et donc je
lui dis à vous baba venez je vais me
faire en trompe à monter on est dans
l'ascenseur je lui dis c'est un enfer
l'imprimante de marche plus depuis deux
heures heureusement que vous êtes arrivé
faut imprimer tout les chiches et tout
est là le gars me regarder mais excusez
moi je viens pas du tout pour ça j'ai
rendez vous avec cyril hanouna ok je dis
vous êtes qui ne sais pas je m'appelle
gaël monfils mais non
mais non
[Applaudissements]
c'était très gênant et le reconnais moi
j'en passe et avec joey starr en fait
vous dire j'étais sur un festival à
trouville festival de cinéma avec ma
compagne que j'avais emmené pour
l'occasion oui et il a cru que c'était
elle qui allait faire les interviews
donc il a accepté
d'écouter il a fait toute une interview
avec le masque de en massacrant que
c'est ma pire internal mance et milan 3
et wii à moisan nîmes qui a commencé
très très bien mais qui s'est mal
terminé j'étais assise au plaza athénée
entre alain delon et michel serrault si
les c'était je crois qu'ils avaient le
gall vais pas dire de jouer et
[Rires]
donc c'était c'était formidable on a
pris un fou rire mais un fou rire et
abandonné j'ai fait ça j'ai loupé la
table je me suis retenu de l'autre main
et j'ai amené avec moi toute la nar et
donc du coup je suis tombé en arrière la
fumée retomber sur nos marques ouvert
aux grenats pas comme ça vous êtes
définitivement de la paix
c'est bien pourquoi thomas puis j'ai
remarqué jean-michel interview dicaprio
oui
mais non si si en boîte à paris mais
nous boîte qui a fermé depuis l'a déjà
raconté oui mais non
[Rires]
comment
tu t'es une expo grand palais à paris
c'est le patron de la boîte c'était un
pote à moi il m'avait bien placé dans le
carré vip j'avais la meilleure table
avec des potes etc des copies nexterra
et avant il vient boire mise en semi
objet de te déplacer à quelqu'un qui
arrive du mit qui arrive qui est plus
important que moi non mais je veux pas
te le dire et tu vas voir effectivement
dix minutes après je vois arriver des
gardes du corps et une dicaprio arriver
qu'une casquette ecsta il se met à ma
table cet [ __ ]
mais lui il y passe inaperçu avec sa
casquette guitare et moi c'était la
grande époque de tp tout le monde aime
prendre en photo du coup il a fini par
part contre un peu la rage de me voir
que jamais plus d'importance que lui il
a fait appeler par ses gardes du corps
il m'a fait appeler par ses gardes du
corps et âmes et wario etc quand
j'utilise démission de jean-michel
gentil
le fan shop et quand je lui dis ce que
je faisais juste assis et les gardes du
corps mort à couper des motards
s'accroît quand même jalousé par
dicaprio
y avaler des américains dans
l'émission de laurent ruquier n'a des
americans à un puncheur l'un des
américains non mais n'ont pu soumettre
tu m'avais poser la question est ce qu
il a toujours pas beaucoup de balles et
y revient sur son plateau apprend qu'il
faut qu'ils en aient en changer pour
passer à la suivante